well welcome back you might say that
british politics is rotten at the moment
to its core so who better to ask about
it than john lydon aka
johnny roth who joins me now john great
to talk to you again uh what do you make
of today boris johnson resigning and the
state in british politics
what an exciting day in politics right
and i'm in the middle of trying to
record an album and you know the teddy
bears picnic
it's happening all over again i've
always viewed him as a bit of a teddy
right
not an honest one but at least amusing
from time to time but i don't understand
what it is has he resigned or not and
how long is that nonsense going to go on
and
is this really damn healthy for the
country that your conservative party
doesn't have an immediate alternative
that's worrying me because i view the
left at the moment as an absolute living
nightmare right i don't want that lot in
and the only joy i've got to look
forward to really
is that labor might lose kirstana
sometime soon well it's a very late well
it's a very interesting point because
he's we're waiting to hear from durham
police about whether he may be fined for
apparently breaking lockdown rules if he
is fine he's already said he'll go so we
could end up losing the prime minister
and the opposition leader all in the
same few days
for breaking their own rules yeah well
exactly forgive me why do i find
politicians foolish
you know i i really want to like trust
them and believe them but here's the
basic truth which i've always liked
adhered to all politicians are liars
they have to be by the very nature it's
all about blending this with that or the
other but narcissus yes there's a word
that several people use today seems to
be the predominant factor and you're in
at 250 to one there's a now what do you
think of my chances
would you vote for me
i probably would but you know who i'd
like i'd like even more
yeah and i know this is like way out and
he's he's probably not even in the
runnings right is uh rhys mogg
because there's something about that man
yeah really i love that world war ii
respect put britain first attitude he
has
and and in every interview i've ever
seen him do he has me on the floor with
his humor do you know what i do think
about i tell you what i think he's just
genuinely a nice person i'll tell you
what i do think about reese blog it's
quite interesting actually because what
i do feel is it's been a dramatic
reduction in basic manners and civility
in public life generally and and
definitely in politics there's been a
course thing of it with trump and
everything else
i do think that when you listen to reece
smog i met him over there to party with
his mother actually and he's a very
charming polite guy i don't agree with a
lot of his politics but he certainly
understands how to be respectful and to
have respect for you you don't have to
because because he has civility
i and that makes him interesting yeah
and it makes debate and conversation
interesting and there's just too much of
this bloody nonsense running now today
i've been trying to watch your channel
on and off because you know i'm
recording an album
i'll run out of money if i'm not careful
over boris
but
it's a there was a couple of people you
had on there this afternoon one was uh i
can't remember his name
but he was from cornwall he was going on
about his working class steve baker yeah
yeah our come on man that's a wrap do
you know what i thought about him
love of it he did he loved himself
didn't he really
yeah
so he was full of himself um
but i do think at least he was open
about being so cocky i quite actually
find it quite refreshing um john it's
great to talk to you uh who do you think
would be who do you think will be the
next prime minister if you're repetitive
first day
first day out of the races the
greyhounds are off right yeah none of
these are going to be winners i don't
know who that mystery dullard ben
wallace is people seem to like him and
he's done something good about national
security penny morgan pro brexit wore a
red dress um is that it really
yeah great to talk to you
as always get back to your house when
you want to flush your toilet when you
want to flush your toilet use blue when
he wants to know who wet the bed go red
john good to talk to you take care mate
all the very best john lydon